now some developing news out of Italy
this hour and an unwelcome milestone in
many ways because the number of covert
90 deaths has risen by four hundred and
twenty seven to three thousand four
hundred and five which means that it is
overtaken or has overtaken China's total
number of deaths our correspondent Sally
Lockwood is in Rome this evening and it
is turning into quite a desperate story
there Sally that's right mark Italy now
has the greatest loss of life globally a
rather huge and horrifying milestone for
this country and it's made particularly
more grim because Italy still has far
fewer cases of covert 19 of coronavirus
than China now it's in part down to
Italy's older population it has the
second oldest population in the world
after Japan but it's also in part down
to the pressure on the healthcare system
that we are seeing in the north in
Lombardi to give you an idea of the
pressure and how bad things are up there
the military was called in overnight to
help transport some of the bodies
because the infrastructure there is
simply not coping the mayor of Bergamo
who spoke to me a few days ago explained
he'd had to close the cemetery because
they can no longer cope with the
hundreds dying there every day the
church in the cemetery had been turned
into a temporary morgue
and soldiers were called in overnight to
transport some of the coffins away in in
army vehicles NAT Lombardi has one of
the most sophisticated healthcare
systems in Europe but they are now
lacking just the basics they are lacking
staff ventilators oxygen beds eight
percent of the people who have been
infected with corona virus in Italy are
medical staff meanwhile 60 million
people in the country remain on a strict
lockdown something that was extended
today that was expected to be lifted on
the 3rd of April and now it is in place
with no end date we've been keeping an
eye on the number of people dying in the
UK and how that compares to Italy it is
following a very similar
and there's no guarantee that it's going
to escalate in the same way here but we
simply don't know nevertheless the UK
and other European countries are
following a strikingly similar path
you